President Macron has said that France must
not give in to fashionable trends when it comes to
the inclusion of gender neutral language.
In the opening of a new museum of the French language,
Macron further added that in French,
the masculine is neutral.
We don't need to add hints in the middle of words
or hyphens to make it readable.
This is not an isolated incident,
as French Senator Pascal Gruni
from lay Republicans has introduced
a Bill is now being debated.
It would ban the use of inclusive language in public
and business settings,
with the proposed Bill limiting the change of language
in all cases where the legislator
and possibly the regulatory authority
requires a document in French.
Similar debate was held a couple of years ago in 2021
over a similar Bill,
when the Academy Francise,
the main body concerning itself with
the safeguarding of the French language,
said that gender inclusiveness would put
the French language in mortal danger.